okay so um basically uh so I was reading
back on Malachi so one thing that was
bothering me a lot also is uh how in
Malachi 4 it was saying that Elijah is
supposed to come
back yeah before the end time yes and
then Matthew St Matthew says that it was
St John the Baptist yep so what's the
problem there well I guess like the
problem is just the fact I don't know
because when I read malachite I know
that Elijah went into heaven okay now
number one when people say the Elijah
went to heaven if you read second Kings
chapter 2 carefully it says a chariot of
fire took him up in heaven now is it
saying took him up to heaven or the sky
that Elisha
sees Elijah being transported in the sky
and taking away so it's not necessarily
the case that Elijah was taken to
God's Heavenly presence he was taken in
a chariot of fire and then the Chariot
of fire sped off into the sky and
disappeared but he wasn't taken to
heaven where God is he was taken to the
realm of the dead because if you read
the New Testament carefully especially
how the church fathers understood and
I'm not appealing to the church fathers
some people don't care no one entered
God's heavly presence until Jesus rose
from the dead and physically bodily
ascended heaven and opened the way for
for them so number one Elijah was
transported by Chariots of Fire where
they took him off and Elijah saw them
flying through the sky because the word
Heaven Can mean sky or it can mean space
or it can mean the Abode of God and then
he was transported to the realm of the
dead so that's number one but number two
go to your question about
Elijah um about how in Matthew it said
that Elijah was St John the Baptist yes
so why is that wrong give me your
question so I can understand where
where's the problem so I can answer for
you um because it doesn't really say in
Malachi that someone that will represent
Elijah do you know why you think that do
you know why you think that in Malachi
45-6 because you didn't read Malachi 31
you read it out of context Malachi 3:1
told you that the Elijah to come is not
Elijah per se but a messenger sent ahe
of the Lord to prepare his coming who's
then called Elijah so now the debate is
is the messenger El or is elahe because
you read Malachi 4-6 but the prophecy
starts in malach
3:1
okay Malachi 3 verse1 now I am sending
my messenger he will prepare the way
before me and the Lord whom you seek
will come suddenly to his Temple the
messenger of the Covenant whom you
desire now Malachi 3:1 I will send my
messenger Mali my angel ahead of me to
prepare my way then when he shows up the
lordon will suddenly appear in his
Temple who's the angel of the Covenant
whom you people desire so notice it says
I'm going to send my Messenger
right then you go to Malachi
45-6 and you can either assume that
messenger Elijah or the messenger called
Elijah because he's a type of Elijah so
now let's go to Matthew 11 read 10 to 15
where Jesus quotes Malachi 3:1 about
John the Baptist and says he is
Elijah okay Matthew 11
10-15 this is the one about Whom It is
written behold I'm sending my messenger
ahead of you he will prepare your way
before you where did you just read that
didn't did you just read that 31 right
now keep reading see what Jesus says
about John the Baptist um and I say to
you among those born of women there has
been none greater than John the Baptist
yet the least in the Kingdom of Heaven
is greater than he from the days of John
the Baptist until now the Kingdom of
Heaven suffers violence and the violence
are taken it by force all the prophets
and the law prophesied up to the time of
John and if you're willing to accept it
he is Elijah the one who is to come
there you
go did you see what Jesus said that was
verse 14 finish it to 15 Whoever has
ears to hear ought to hear did you catch
it if you have eyes to see ears to hear
he is Elijah because it's not Elijah's
coming because God already told you
Malachi 3:1 a messenger is coming whom
God calls Elijah because he is an Elijah
Tye okay so where's the problem if we
read from Malachi 3:1 not started
Malachi
45-6 then here in Malachi 3:1 it's a
messenger now God could have simply said
I will send Elijah he didn't he said I
will send a messenger because when the
Lord comes he then unpacks the fullness
of the Revelation the messenger is
called Elijah because he's like Elijah
Elijah is a picture of him but it's not
actually Elijah it's John the
Baptist okay it's just like when
scripture calls Jesus Israel and David
two of the names given to Jesus he's
called David and he's called Israel not
because David would come and Reign or
the nation would save the world but
because Jesus is a type of David a type
of Israel or I should say David and
Israel are types of Jesus because they
point to Jesus
and are you aware that even in rabic
Tradition they'll tell you one of the
names of Messiah is David because there
are passages in the Old Testament that
talk about David and even the rabbis
said this not David it's about Messiah
whom David
prefigures like in Hosea yep Hosea 3
4-5 Jeremiah 23
5-6 see okay so did that help you yeah
it did so you see how amazingly deep the
Bible is
wow okay so where's the problem if you
read Malachi 3:1 to 4 chapter 4 vers 5-6
now you can argue that messenger of 31
is Elijah or that that messenger is
called Elijah because he's a type of
Elijah in other words no Rabbi can prove
conclusively it's Elijah himself who's
coming because Malachi 3:1 already told
me that it's a messenger being
sent whom God calls Elijah but doesn't
mean he has to be Elijah just like the
rabbis agree there passages where
messiah's called David but it doesn't
mean he's
David okay and so when I come to Jesus
and his inspired Apostles they quote
notice they quote Malachi 3:1 and say
it's about John in the same context
where John is called
Elijah you just read it right yes and
why is he called Elijah now go to Luke 1
and read 15- 17 okay
Luke one and chapter Luke 1 15 15- 17
okay for he will be great in the sight
of the Lord he will drink neither wine
nor strong drink he will be filled with
the Holy Spirit even from his mother's
womb and he will turn many of the
children of Israel to the Lord their
God he will go before him in the spirit
and power of Elijah to turn the hearts
of fathers toward children and the
Disobedience to the understanding of the
righteous to prepare a people fit for
the Lord Lord there's Malachi 45-6 he
will go in the spirit and power of
Elijah you see verse 17 yeah so the same
holy spirit that filled Elijah and
empowered him will be the same Holy
Spirit filling John and empowering him
to do something similar to
Elijah okay so any other problems with
that um I don't really not not with him
being identified as Elijah but I'm
curious about the part of turning the
hearts of Father towards children and
what's the whole point of that it means
because he will reconcile people who are
in enmity animosity and hatred because
that's that's common even today families
are divided families are
not United families attack each other
and so what he's going to do is he's
going to turn the sons back to honoring
their fathers instead of dishonoring
them and vice versa he's going to bring
reconciliation peace if they heed the
message and
repent okay and going to be restoration
to society to societal structures
restoration of families restoration of
neighbors Restoration in other words
this
societal dysfunction where you see the
violence the hatred the division
parents killing children or attacking
ing children or dising children or
abusing children children dishonoring
parents killing
par neighbors no longer being neighborly
all of that he will be sent forth to
restore provided they hear and obey the
message okay and did he do that to those
who belied yes it's like ask me today
did Jesus bring
peace did he
peace I mean I guess it depends what you
mean by peace well however you want to
Define it did he bring peace yes well if
he brought peace then why do so many
people hate us and attack us and slander
us and why are we constantly being
abused and threatened because the answer
is he brings peace to those who accept
his
peace okay what if you don't accept
it then there's no peace and what if you
oppose it
then there's still Division and then
what if those who do accept this pece
and want to live in accord with his Rule
and obey his will in their life are
confronted by those who hate Christ hate
his will hate his word how they going to
treat
you they're going to persecute us that's
the point so when he say did he do that
he did it for those who will accept and
embrace his
rule okay but if you don't accept his
rule then how can you have peace because
Jesus is the source of peace so then to
deny the source of peace and oppose the
source of peace then you will not have
peace but you're going to have chaos and
judgment and wrath the opposite of peace